you've almost certainly heard of mr
beast the 15th largest youtube channel
by subscriber count
made famous for doing extreme stunts
when you see a mr beast thumbnail
your first thought is there's no way
that's real
there's no way he actually gave a random
fan
40 cars there's no way he
actually bought a private island or
planted 20 million
trees if the internet has taught us
anything
it's don't believe what you see today
if you really were the one millionth
visitor you'd never know
and yet jimmy donaldson actually follows
through
it's honest click bait in a way that
brings back some of that early internet
magic
and in december mr beast did it again
this time by opening mr beast burger an
actual restaurant where he handed out
free stacks of cash
apple products and yes even a few
burgers
at the end of the video viewers at home
were told
they too could order a burger from one
of its 300 locations across the country
residents of towns as small as evanston
wyoming
population 11 000 and topsham maine
population 8 000 were surprised to find
they too had a local mr beast burger
location
the app was so popular in fact that it
crashed on that first day two months
later
over a million burgers had been sold
now mr beast had the unique advantage of
not needing to spend a dime on marketing
which might make this whole concept look
like just another influencer brand or
publicity stunt but the most fascinating
thing about mr beastberger
is the fact that it's actually not
unique the way he opened
300 locations in only a matter of months
is the same way tens of thousands of
restaurants have stayed alive during the
pandemic
and a sign of where the restaurant
industry might be headed
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch the extended version
of this video
no industry has been left untouched by
the pandemic
but some have been forced to adapt more
than others
while airlines were handed over 25
billion dollars in direct grants
small local restaurants were left to
fend for themselves
according to the national restaurant
association 131 billion dollars in sales
were lost in just the first five months
of the pandemic alone
tragic as these circumstances were they
unintentionally created the optimal
conditions for a kind of restaurant
revolution just as residents of new york
city
l.a and the bay area found themselves
paying insane rent with no access to the
city they
loved and decided to take their money
elsewhere restaurant owners
soon came to that same realization they
were still paying for the best real
estate
but who on the other side of a delivery
app would notice if they moved across
town and why stop there if customers
never see
inside the restaurant why pay for
decorations
bathrooms even signs or tables
that's the basic premise behind what are
called cloud
virtual dark or ghost kitchens somewhat
ambiguous terms for restaurants that
don't exist
at least not in the way we typically
think of them
if you've ordered food delivery in the
past few years and if the name of the
restaurant sounded a bit
strange or unfamiliar there's a decent
chance
you've already ordered from one that's
because
they aren't entirely new restaurants and
food trucks have long been able to rent
commissary kitchens as they're known in
the industry to prepare their food
in recent times however and especially
as a response to the pandemic
restaurants have found clever ways of
taking this concept
further one company called reef
technology
for example owns thousands of parking
lots across the country
which of course have mostly sat empty
to make up for lost revenue it placed
delivery-only kitchen trailers in over
90 of its parking lots
with recipes licensed from other
restaurants
kroger the country's largest grocery
chain did something similar by launching
ghost kitchens
inside several of its stores red robin
applebee's chipotle and wendy's to name
just a few
also now operate delivery-only locations
other restaurants stayed put but found
new ways to extract value from their
fixed assets
one of the biggest problems with
restaurants in general
is that for the most part people only
eat during certain times of the day
which means equipment staff and valuable
real estate
sit unused for most of the 24-hour day
but nothing says they have to in the
same way that airbnb
and turo allow individuals to make extra
money from the time they're not using
their home
or car many restaurants now rent out
their unused kitchen time
which is how mr beast pulled off mr
beast burger
your delivery driver will never see a mr
beast sign
instead they might be directed to a
bravo italian kitchen
or hero's grill real restaurants whose
kitchens have been hired by mr beast to
produce his burgers using his
recipes guy fieri also partnered with
existing restaurants to create 130
flavor town kitchens
another way for restaurants to make some
extra cash is by launching their own
ghost kitchens a mexican restaurant for
example
might launch a delivery-only brand of
japanese food
operating out of the same kitchen
without any of its customers knowing the
difference
you can even buy a ghost kitchen
franchise package
for an upfront fee of two thousand
dollars chicago-based wow bow
will send you all the training and
equipment you need to sell its asian
food
out of your restaurant in fact some have
turned this into a feature
since multiple brands are cooked from
the same kitchen they allow you to mix
and match cuisines for the same delivery
fee
so for example you could order some
tacos sushi
and bubble tea all at the same time
usually though
customers have no idea where their food
comes from
last year for instance a woman in
philadelphia ordered pizza from what she
believed to be a locally owned
restaurant
when it arrived it tasted a bit familiar
and not in a good way after doing some
digging she discovered this
local restaurant was actually chuck e
cheese
using a fictional name on grubhub it's
reminiscent of the white label industry
on
amazon where sellers buy repackage
and resell products under different
brand names
for better or worse this is the next
frontier in the
industry the amazonification of food
kitchens are slowly becoming anonymous
warehouses
you don't know or care where your
packages come from
and increasingly neither do we know or
care where our food does
at least that's the hope of companies
like cloud kitchens
the we work for restaurants funded with
a 400 million dollar investment by saudi
arabia's sovereign wealth fund
the company starts by shopping around
for cheap distressed
properties dying bowling alleys auto
repair shops and warehouses
within each of these buildings it
constructs tiny 200 square foot kitchen
cubicles
which chefs can rent on a monthly basis
these shared spaces contain everything a
delivery-only restaurant
needs grills sinks wi-fi electricity
dishwashers and so on some might argue
this takes away all the fun of owning
and operating a restaurant
but there are also advantages think
about it this way
there are good chefs and there are good
business people
some people are both but not all that
means
right now we're missing out on a lot of
good food simply because
some good chefs don't have good business
skills
services like cloud kitchens lower the
barrier to entry
which moves the two circles closer
together
the parallels between cloud kitchens and
silicon valley
are no coincidence the man behind cloud
kitchens
is none other than travis kalanick
former ceo of uber
before he was forced to resign following
a long string of scandals
the question is why restaurants for all
his tech bro
antics and reprehensible behavior no one
doubts kalanick's strategic business
mind
and yet the restaurant industry is
famously
low margin and high risk food
is not software there are few overnight
successes
and there are natural physical limits on
growth
there's a reason in other words none of
the world's largest companies are
involved in food
and why is loud flashy outspoken
kalanick hiding from the spotlight
making sure
cloud kitchens keeps a low media profile
it would seem kalanick is quietly biding
his time
waiting to launch a revolution of the
restaurant industry
cloud kitchens wants to become the
amazon of food
and if anyone can pull it off it's
probably the man behind uber
this is where i explain kalanick's
vision for the future of food
and why he might just be on to something
in the extended version of this video
on nebula just about every other
polymatter video has an extra long
extended version
in part one of china's reckoning for
example i explained why the u.s
is not headed for the same demographic
collapse as
china despite having a similar fertility
rate
nebula is the streaming site i helped
create to give a home to more
experimental
long-form and special videos like
sam from wendover's trivia show joe
scott's mysteries of the human body
and h-bomber guy's breakdown of the true
detective intro
there are no ads videos are available
early and you can watch
entirely exclusive original content
we've partnered with curiositystream
home to great documentaries on
technology
history and science like this one about
why china has one
last remaining steam train so that you
can get it
and nebula for less than 15 bucks a year
sign up with the link in the description
and watch the extended version of this
video
over on nebula